South Korea says the North has blown up
an inter-korean liaison office
it was located in Chi song at the border
North Korea has made several threats
against South Korea in recent days
including threatening to destroy the
office which was set up in 2018 let's
bring in Roe McBride from South Korea's
capital Seoul Robert welcome what more
can you tell us this is a very serious
development it's not completely out of
the blue they have been making threats
for some time from the North against
deteriorating relations of course all of
this comes against the background of
stalled denuclearization talks between
North Korea and the United States which
has impacted inter-korean relations with
North Korea accusing the south of making
matters worse and so on so there have
been increasingly threatening noises
from North Korea and especially in the
past week or so they have been angered
by the planned release by by by groups
here in South Korea of defectors who had
planned to release balloons with
propaganda messages into the north this
is always angered the North Koreans they
have objected making threats the South
Koreans had said that they were taking
action to try to prevent this they knew
that things were at a tipping point and
in fact over the weekend kim yo-jong
that is the sister of kim jong-un had
said specifically that they sell the
Azon office in Kaesong was a symbol of
the improving relations between North
and South would soon become just a
smoldering building leaving it up to the
military to take the next step well it
seems this Tuesday afternoon as though
the military has taken that step we had
during the afternoon reports from a
Yonhap news agency here on the border of
seeing smoke rising from the building
also hearing an explosion and it's being
confirmed by the Unification Ministry
here in Seoul that's the department that
handles inter-korean relations that it
has been detonated has seemingly been
destroyed we are still waiting for
confirmation from that from North Korea
but it seems as though they have carried
out on their threat and robbed this
j'onn office was set up back in 2018 so
obviously things were really looking
quite good back then in terms of
relations between the two absolutely I
mean but where this was set up this is a
joint economic zone which was held up as
a symbol of improving relations South
Korean companies would set up operations
in the north to employ North Korean
workers as the relations steadily
worsened through 2017 2020 18 then the
that was shuttered no businesses were
allowed to operate there but as they
gradually improved again all throughout
last year it was decided that that would
be the place for this new liaison office
to to have a continued dialogue to try
to improve relations across the DMZ and
incedent the president of South Korea
moon jae-in has said despite worsening
relations he is still determined to try
to look for ways of improving relations
to work ahead but of course his options
for doing that for trying to restore
relations or even just get in touch with
the north are hampered because the all
of the hotlines between north and south
have now been cut he has no way
officially of trying to get in touch
with his North Korean counterparts
thank you very odd McBride there live
from Seoul